Hấp cái tuần gặp của mình luôn.
Bạn có năm căm, khoảng 1,5%
1,5%
Đấy các bạn có phải phải tương con 2,
2,5%
Các bạn có thể có thể có thể có thể có thể
Hấp cái tuần gặp của mình luôn
Đối ăn,
Con sĩ quuyên của đáy này như sao?
Các bạn hay ra hướng vâng
Sây gòn,
Các chúng ta sẽ gòn con 3,5%
Các bạn sẽ mua đúng một lo đó con 2,5%
2,5%
Vái mua tự trả cho các bạn lại có 1 lạm.
Các bạn có giúp nợ
Và các bạn
Dữ lối lối lối được này từ 6,5%
Bố nước năm năm nữa
Cái bạn bán cái lối lối được này
Vào trong vòng bố nước năm năm này
Nếu làm thế nào để giả tăng thung nhập để kẻ 2 cái xú vô vòng vòng mục tảy
Nếu các bạn có thể có thể có thể có thể ngốc
Và nếu được trực 1,5%
Các bạn sẽ sách cái xú tây này nữa
Thì sau năm năm, các bạn bán cái lối lối đó này ra
Các bạn có thể về xe gòn
Các bạn sẽ mua đúng không cần chung tư,
Bảo đảm
Chắc chung tư là một cái chung tư
Không có buồn tìm vào lúc
Với 2,5%
Các bạn bán bà dựa tình giống bó đồng sản của người sau mọng của phục bánh két
Bình giữ mà bây giờ là bánh két tụt là bối chung tư
2 là khu vọc lòng thàn 3 khu vùng nghiệm kèp
Bố là khu vụt bà để vũ tạo
Các bạn nhé như phục nè rất khóc giận
Ở vì kia tìm bận đồng sản
Những khu khu lệng là tà làm ngày xưa
Chân ngày xưa là đất là em
Chuyện lỗi 1 đất xưa
Đất đồng khóc
Mọi người có nơi hơi sau thì nhấn
Mọi con khán sẽ bị sáng nhỏ thi
Két nơi hơi không
Phải anh tìt